this is the single thing that makes the
biggest difference in people's results
for learning any anything at all and
that is that
we learn by testing ourselves we don't
learn by reading stuff and this is again
a seem is
is counterintuitive because when you
tell people that they they should test
themselves and stuff they'll say oh well
i i have to learn it first
and then i can revise it and then i'll
test myself for the exam there's
evidence that shows that if you test
yourself even before you start learning
something that's going to improve your
learning if you test yourself
immediately after you learn something
that's going to improve your learning if
the only thing you do
after reading something is just test
yourself once that is better than
reading the same thing four times or
writing a summary of it or creating a
mind map on it all you have to do is
just test yourself
ali welcome to the show thank you very
much for having me i was going to say
it's always
a bit strange to hear a british accent
on the end of like a productivity or
like a you know
a just like any kind of podcast because
like all of the ones i listen to
are just so overwhelmingly american that
when i when i hear a brit it's like oh
it's one of my voices it's my people
this is my people
here who do you listen to oh like all of
the things i'm sure you do uh started
out with tim ferriss and then
farnam street and i've got like 80 on my
podcast uh library thing which is
you know now swelling um i've recently
started listening to a lot of dave
asprey as well because i'm trying to get
into the whole like hacking your health
and
and all that stuff dabbled with a bit of
peter right here these are all like
white american dudes though so i need a
bit of variety in my in my podcast diet
yeah i get that i know that we're both
mutual friends of chris sparks thiago
forte
uh have you been introduced to taylor
pearson yet uh i know of him through his
website and stuff but i haven't spoken
to him personally
phenomenal writer absolutely wonderful
writer um
so today we're going to be talking about
how to learn and remember anything
fast this is right slap bang in your
wheelhouse i think
yeah man this is like my specialist
subject
take off what was it like mastermind
oh yeah junior yeah mastermind that i'm
not sure if that's still on but i used
to fantasize about going on
on the tv show and at the time my
specialist subject would have been
the harry potter books and i still think
it probably would
it probably would still be you reckon um
yeah that's the only thing i actually
know anything about but apart from that
studying is another
another specialist interest got you so
where do we begin
people are now just about arriving back
to university perhaps
we have people who are maybe even
venturing into a new career postcovide
or
looking to become increasingly
competitive in a job market
they want to be able to consume retain
deploy information and learning and
comprehension and all this stuff
where do we even begin yeah
that's a good question i'd say probably
the main
principle that everything else hinges on
is that learning is supposed to be
effortful
it's supposed to be hard um and it's
it's so it's sort of like the analogy i
sometimes use for my students
is it's like when you're going to the
gym if you're lifting weights that you
can easily lift
you're not actually going to make any
gains it's just going to be a total
waste of time
but it's when you start doing that
progressive overload when you start
lifting weights that are that are at the
limit of what you're able to do
that gives your muscles the stimulus for
growth and then you know assuming you
eat right and you sleep well
then you're gonna get more hench and
you're gonna you're gonna be able to
lift more weight
and it's sort of somewhat equivalent for
learning that the harder it feels to
learn something
the more likely that information is to
stick and
this is very counterintuitive right
because
still to this day despite all of the
decades of research that have been done
about this that show that when learning
is effortful it's
better despite all of that evidence most
teachers uh still focus on trying to
make the content as convenient as
possible for their students
like very well meaning teachers who want
to sort of categorize things into nice
syllabuses and create a nice
presentation and give them mnemonics and
essentially take all of the difficulty
out of studying for the student
essentially give them this packaged up
thing that they just have to learn
but in doing so the thing that they're
packaging up that the student just has
to learn it actually makes it a lot
harder for them to learn because the
student then
is not putting in any of the effort
themselves and so they have to start
finding weird ways to put effort into it
so that is probably principle number one
that all of the rest of the kind of
learning theory is based on
don't expect it to be easy and almost
lean into the discomfort a little bit
that if you are finding something
challenging to learn that that's a
signal that
it it's doing the work yeah exactly and
it's it's one of those things where
like i feel like there are very few
domains in life where
conventional wisdom is directly opposite
to what actually works
but certainly when it comes to studying
and learning conventional wisdom is that
we feel like we're stupid if if what we
have to learn is hard if we're
struggling through school or if we're
struggling to understand a concept we
think oh i must be dumb i must not be
doing this right
but in fact it's the exact opposite like
if you're
finding something hard it's a lot more
likely to stick because your brain is
having to work harder
you're operating at your at the limit of
your i don't know your muscles potential
and then that's the stimulus for growth
and then that's the stimulus for those
connections to form
so that it becomes slightly easier the
next time around what
else do most people get wrong about
learning
uh so a few things though there have
been some really cool studies about this
where um because essentially
college and university students are a
great crop of people to do studies on
because you can pay them like three
pounds and they'll happily kind of sign
up to do anything
there's been this whole swath of studies
about learning and studying and
memorization done on
college and union university students um
the other things that really make a
difference are
and this is probably you know apart from
the fact that learning needs to be
effortful this is
the single thing that makes the biggest
difference in people's results
for learning anything at all and that is
that
we learn by testing ourselves we don't
learn by reading stuff
and this is again it seems is is
counterintuitive because
when you tell people that they they
should test themselves and stuff
they'll say oh well i i have to learn it
first and then i can revise it and then
i'll test myself for the exam
and there's a really good book called
make it stick which is all about the
science of successful learning
and the authors basically say right up
front in in the introduction that look
if you're a student or any kind of
learner and you're not happy with the
way your results are going
chances are you're just not testing
yourself enough there's evidence that
shows that if you test yourself even
before you start learning something
that's going to improve your learning if
you test yourself immediately after you
learn something that's going to improve
your learning
if the only thing you do after reading
something is just test yourself once
that is better than reading the same
thing four times
or writing a summary of it or creating a
mind map on it all you have to do is
just test yourself
and again this is so this is so country
intuitive
um we kind of think of in we we kind of
think of studying and learning
as if it's a process of putting
information into our brains
but in fact it is the opposite it's the
process of getting information out of
our brains and in
trying to retrieve stuff that is what's
forming the connections
whereas when we're just reading things
or rereading things or summarizing
things
with the book open we're falling into
that trap of thinking that
familiarity is the same thing as
understanding um and you've probably
seen this i certainly give this a lot
where i've read something enough times
where i think oh yeah obviously i know
this
but then if you ask me you know can you
actually explain it in your own words
without looking at the book
i'd be like oh okay maybe not and again
yeah and there is some evidence as well
that
the the emotional component of it is
identical across
across both of these domains so for
example if you were to read something
that you've come across before
and you read through it and you think oh
yeah i recognize this it feels really
good because you think oh yeah i know
the stuff i know what's going on
it's exactly the same feeling as if you
try and recall something completely from
memory
and you get it right and you think oh
that's cool and so because we're so used
to
rereading stuff and reviewing our notes
and we have this topic of
revising as if revising like revision
like going over stuff again is gonna
help
it feels good it feels productive but as
all the studies show
and as everyone who's tried this in real
life shows rereading stuff doesn't
actually help you learn it
testing yourself on stuff does help you
learn it it's
familiarity masquerading as
comprehension exactly yeah that's
exactly what it is
i had a i had peter c brown on the show
he was like
episode 19 two and a half years ago
so anyone that's interested in this and
wants to dig into make it stick the book
is
really accessible super good read um and
a nice primer for that is
it's like back in the teens please
please
ignore everything about my hosting
ability and my sound quality but
peter's pete's fantastic on it um and
from that
the one sentence summary of make it
stick
is memorization comes from repeated
recall
not repeated exposure oh
that's a good phrase i need to start
stealing that that's fine man
you can note it down at 145 words per
minute on your on your mechanical
keyboard
doesn't make too much noise though on
the recording that's what i worry about
what i'm doing is considered a silenced
keyboard
yeah occasionally i switch to my apple
magic keyboard which is a little bit
more quiet
if i'm doing a live stream i'm having to
switch windows on the fly because
that's a bit it's a bit obnoxious yeah
it is um okay
so we know that we need to lean into the
discomfort we also know that um
just continuing to read i mean everyone
knows everyone that's listening
has been that person or knows that
person who's like the flash card addict
who's got everything laid out in a
million color coded
written and this that any other but
doesn't ever actually end up doing the
testing and what you're saying is that
we need to focus on the recall we need
to focus on the testing those are two
nice principles to start us off
where do we go next um i'd say next
the third principle that i was talking
about is one that's called spaced
repetition and this is again something
that peter brown talks about in in the
book
the idea of space repetition is um
we've all had this experience where you
learn something and then
or you think you've understood a topic
and you come back to it like a day or a
week later
and it's completely gone um and again
when we when
when this happens to us if we're
students we often think oh i must be
dumb i must be thick because i'm not
remembering this thing
and we'll look at the students around us
and we'll say oh but tom over there
from singapore you know he seems to
memorize things as soon as he reads them
uh but what tom from singapore is
actually doing is that he's not
memorizing things the instantly reads
them there's no such thing as a
photographic memory
what he's doing is that he's just
revising he's he's
repeating the the topic more than once
and i don't know when
i don't know how this came into the sort
of mainstream where people think that
you should just be able to recall
something after coming across it once
uh it would be completely ridiculous in
any other domain of life like if you're
learning a song on the piano like
obviously you have to practice it more
than once to get it right
if you're trying to improve your tennis
or squash swing obviously you have to
practice more than once
but we think for some reason at least
everyone on your university felt this
way that oh if i don't
if i don't get it first time i must be
an idiot and the idea of space
repetition is that it combats the
forgetting curve
so back in the 1800s there was this dude
called ebbinghaus
who did a really weird experiment on
himself whereby he made himself memorize
a bunch of completely nonsense words
like completely made up words
uh not even the meaning just to see how
much he could brute force into his
memory
and he plotted out how long it took him
to forget
each of these words as he memorized them
and he found that it was like one of
those exponential decay half-lifey
uh graphs if anyone's familiar with
those whereby
you lose the majority of it in the
initial period and then the forgettings
kind of slows down so this is the
forgetting curve
and the idea is that if we repeat the
the subject by testing ourselves on it
and then by looking it up if we if we
got it wrong that
takes us back up to 100 memory uh but
crucially
the more we do that the slower this
curve decays
and so for example something like the
capital of francis paris
you've come across that fact enough
times in your life through various means
when you were younger that
you're never really going to forget it
and that's because
accidentally you've had this space
repetition thing applied to it
whereas if someone told you the capital
of i don't know some random country is
some random city
right now you would forget it unless you
came across that fact again and again
and again and when you come across it
enough times over a long period of time
it goes into your long-term memory and
then you'll know and then you're never
going to forget it
so the idea behind space repetition is
that initially when we learn something
we then want to repeat the testing of it
fairly quickly maybe a day or a few days
later
and then once we've done that we want to
space it out a bit more so maybe a week
later
and then maybe a month later and then
maybe six months later
and so that's the spaced repetition
aspect of it and if we do that
we kind of get our forgetting curve to
be quite shallow and hopefully this
stuff goes into a long-term memory
does that work for all types of learning
i can imagine your background as a med
student i know that we'll
get into it soon i'm sure about anki
which is one of the most
popular space repetition softwares out
there um
that's a lot of kind of rote root very
much brute force memorization yeah
what about if i'm trying to do something
that's a little bit more fluffy
sort of philosophical concepts or um
literature comprehension stuff like that
in theory this should work for
everything
um at least so in in in make at stake
again referencing that book they talk
about a load of domains in which this
this sort of stuff applies it isn't just
for students trying to memorize
biochemical
pathways for medical school it is sort
of hockey players competing in
tournaments it's business people working
in like
in the corporate world in all of these
different aspects of life where people
have done studies
you see this pattern of testing being
super important and spacing also being
super important
there's another book called uh range by
david epstein where he talks about
this basically in those exact terms he
says testing spacing and interleaving
are like the three sort of primary
things for
learning any skill whether whether it's
like knowledge for
a university subject or whether it's
like tennis or golf or anything like
that
how generalists thrive in a specialized
world also
also a past modern wisdom guest just
after that came out so if you want to
get on david x
epstein go back modern wisdom i think he
was around about maybe in the sort of
late 70s something like that
um so this is this is what i've done
every episode up until now
ali has just been a prelude to this one
and this is yeah
it's a [ __ ] pinnacle right here um so
we've got
the testing the recall we've got the
fact that we need to lean into it um and
we've got the fact
that we need to do space repetition are
we on any more principles or should we
start to move into some
uh more strategic stuff now yeah so i
suppose the
the final principle is one that epstein
talks about which is interleaving
and interleaving is the idea that um we
kind of want to be operating
uh in in sort of our area our zone of
discomfort
so the example he gives in uh the
example they given make it stick i think
is looking at hockey coaches
and the way they found that this works
best is
you kind of train people and drill a
particular exercise
but just as your players are on the
verge of getting it and really leaning
into it
at that point you switch completely and
do a different exercise
and as soon as they're on the verge of
kind of getting the hang of that you
switch completely and do another
exercise
and the idea behind this is that it's a
bit annoying for the players because
they're not experiencing that uh you
know that mastery sensation that oh yeah
i know what i'm doing i'm the don
but when when you have that feeling you
you're not really learning anymore
uh and so the idea of interleaving is
that you want to be doing lots of
different things within
a learning session or within a study
session um
and so for example again this isn't how
traditional schooling is designed if
you're having like a maths lesson you
would do
i don't know uh trigonometry and
pythagoras theorem in cincos tan
and you would do it in like a very
specific order
and when you're doing exercises you will
kind of learn something and then you'll
spend the rest of the lesson doing
exercises about that thing that you
learned
where really the only thing that's
changing is just the numbers and the
concept is the same
whereas what the studies show is that if
you have a
if you add a little bit more variety so
you kind of make them do a little bit of
something a little bit of something else
a little bit of something else
the brain is never quite allowed to be
comfortable and therefore we're
maximizing our learning
uh and minimizing the time we have to
take to learn it how do you ensure
that you reach a particular threshold
and you don't
always keep selling yourself short so
that you don't get any comprehension
with anything
yeah i think that's that's where the
balancing act is because
whatever you're studying there is a
level of
a level of time you have to put in to
really engage with the material to kind
of really get the hang of it
um and that's that's the tricky part
the thing that i the thing that i do is
that
as soon as i start feeling that feeling
of oh okay i'm quite enjoying this
at that point i switch tasks so the
interleaving and the discomfort
uh the interleaving is the it's the tool
with which you force the discomfort into
the learning process almost
yes if the learning process itself isn't
just it isn't uncomfortable enough where
you're actually
limit your thing anyway so for example
if i'm doing a completely new
like a brand new topic and i'm really
struggling to understand it i won't
bother doing the interleaving because
it's hard enough
but as soon as i'm at the point where
okay i i understand cardiology i
understand how atrial fibrillation works
then i'm like okay let's let's add in
some hematology to the mixture just just
um spice things up and make it a bit
more interesting for my brain i get it i
get it okay
so where do we go next why don't we talk
about
um some practical stuff let's say that
you're sitting down
to do a session of learning anything
i think that med school actually is a
really good example and it's a
you guys are like the the vanguard of
trying to
hardcore brute force learn [ __ ] trying
to cram as much stuff into your memory
as possible
precisely so talk us through it's
the morning you've woken up you've done
your morning routine um and you think
right
i got some exams coming up at some point
soon
or perhaps you've recently been
introduced to a new area and you're
gonna
you're gonna sit down what what happens
you're outside of the the room where
you're going to do your learning
do you do it in your house do you go
somewhere else and what do you take with
you and what do you sit down with
okay cool um so i think kind of the
environment
is kind of important uh
i i used to think i could work in my
room i've now realized that i much
prefer to work in libraries
and if i could i would actually go to
libraries every day where i have to like
write
write scripts for youtube videos as well
uh but the whole log down thing is
putting a
bit of a bummer on that so i was always
a big fan of
leaving my room and going to the library
and going to this external location
so that in a way i could keep the work
and studying separate
there's also some some evidence that if
you're if you're studying something
in an environment that is similar to the
arena in which you'll be tested on it
then you get a few extra percentage
points of uh
sort of optimization there that's
interesting so for example that's
partly why listening to music while
studying is not considered very good
because you're probably not going to be
listening to music when you're being
tested on the thing
having said that i still listen to music
while i'm studying i listen to
instrumental tracks uh the theory being
that
instrumental stuff doesn't interfere
with the phonological loop which is part
of working memory
um i listen to instrumental tracks
because it's just so much nicer when
i've got the lord of the rings
soundtrack
in my noise cancelling headphones and
i'm quite happy to take
the optimization hit uh if it means i'll
enjoy myself a little bit more
do you think that you would be able to
request upon entry
into an exam the fact that i need to
take one airpod in with me look i
promise it's not the answers playing
here
it's just the two towers battle yeah
just like really get you pumped up
okay so um we've got ourselves into a
location which is
potentially similar lots of wood perhaps
lots of oak around if you're in
the red brick the library is to be
honest if it's one of those modern ones
there won't be much oak around but if
it's an old-fashioned library then sure
get yourself somewhere bourgeois
that's what we want exactly you know
someplace fancy some place where you can
really get into it and think oh yeah
this is what being a student is about
yeah ancient furniture that's what it's
about yeah um
okay so we've gone somewhere that's
similar i i also
totally agree the fact that my bedroom's
30 square meters
is the only reason that i choose to
record here i would much sooner do work
and sleep
in different places it's also the reason
why you shouldn't watch tv in bed
although i know i've got tv that's
behind me
um you should have locations that are
um attached to a particular task thiago
forte would say the same i know chris
sparks would as well
um so we've done that what what else are
you doing
what's next uh essentially what's next
is
figuring out what to do for the day um i
have a strong theory about this which is
that
you shouldn't figure out what you're
going to do in advance and i think this
is usually the way that students
build up their revision timetables it's
like uh
you know you think right i've got three
months until my a levels or whatever
and therefore i'm going to sit down i'm
going to map out syllabus for each of my
subjects and i'm going to figure out
what i'm going to study each day
and in theory if i stick to my plan i
will have covered everything twice by
the time the exam rolls around
that's like the traditional way of
approaching this i've never been a fan
of this method because
firstly it's an exercise in
procrastination we all know when we try
to make a revision timetable is that it
basically takes up the whole day then
you think it's not perfect and so you
think oh you know what i just need to
spend another day doing this and so it
takes up another day
i think also it's generally very
optimistic
uh it you know if you're the sort of
person who can
actually follow the plan that you set
out three months ago then
fair enough i'm definitely not that sort
of person i know very few people who
actually would follow the plan exactly
and it's also kind of like trying to
predict the future in that
you're predicting very quite far out in
advance
which topics you're going to need to
visit more often than which
topics you're going to struggle with and
stuff that seems to be generally a false
error for me so
the way that i do it i call it the
retrospective revision timetable
which is that instead of having a list
of dates down one column
and figuring out when i'm going to study
what i'll instead have a list of topics
down the first column if you imagine
like a spreadsheet with a list of topics
and then each day i will ask myself the
question
if the exam were tomorrow what topic
would i be the most pissed off about
um and i will study that topic and then
once i've studied that topic i'll write
the date next to the topic so that i've
got this general idea of
when i studied each topic and i will
also color code it based on how well i
knew it based on my my testing
so if it's red it's i didn't know it at
all i need to do this very quickly if
it's green it's like okay this is pretty
good i can wait a while before i revisit
this
and so every day i look at my
retrospective revision timetable and
look at where the gaps are and where the
red
is and think okay keeping in mind the
concept of space repetition
and the concept that i want to be doing
the hardest stuff first
what topic should i cover in this next
hour or so
and i'll just repeat that process for as
many hours as i'm doing the studying for
and over time that means that my topics
thing becomes
green across the board but it's it sort
of looks like a jagged
a jagged graph because often chapter one
in a book is a lot easier than chapter
13 in a book
uh but when we you know quote sit down
and start studying we often turn to
chapter one
just because it's easier than turning to
chapter 13. and so some topics will be
easier than others but the point is that
you're not basing what you're doing each
day as a function of what the date is
and what you predicted you were going to
do three months in advance
you're basing it off of what is the most
difficult topic right now
and if the exam will tomorrow what would
i be least happy about let me focus on
that so that i'm again
always operating at the slight level of
discomfort and always maximizing my bang
for buck
because you don't want to get to the
point where you're getting diminishing
returns uh when it comes to the amount
of time that you're putting in
that's like um aggregated spaced
repetition
as well as individual space repetition
obviously with specifically again
med school you can see precisely
like i didn't know this particular thing
to do with cardiology
um and then you're looking you're kind
of aggregating those out into topic
areas that you're
also kind of a bit more [ __ ] at and then
thinking right i'm i'm going to use that
so someone
might be really really good at business
law but bad at criminal law
so you're right okay and then within
that you can drill down a little bit
further what's your views um
before we actually sit down we've got
our plan i'm gonna guess
you would plan for the day you wouldn't
sit down
at a desk and then say right what am i
going to do today you would at least
know
on the morning what was going to be done
that day yeah more or less i'd be like
okay which three topics i'm am i going
to today i'm going to do i don't know
that this bit of cardiology this bit of
hematology and i'll try and memorize the
krebs cycle from biochemistry for
example got you um what's your views on
caffeine as a studying tool
oh i love it i think it's great uh
pretty reasonable evidence for it
uh very little evidence about downsides
i've always been a fan
modafinil or anything more spicy or
exotic i've never really tried any of
those
um at university there was a strict like
no no policy about it
and i i had like a performance enhancing
drugs
at cambridge
um i i had a friend who tried modafinil
and he said that he ended up just sort
of reading the same thing over and over
again for about 16 hours and that kind
of put me off it
but recently i started looking into it a
little bit more and i'm keen to try it
out
um i think it might make for an
interesting video i just have to make
sure it's
legal and not against the requirements
of the general medical council
that says anything you do that brings
the profession into disrepute is grounds
for getting struck off
don't get yourself struck off man yeah
it wouldn't be a good look
i uh i posted today on my instagram
story
um alpha brain from onit and i've been
using alphabet it's
edit days so today i've uh edited and
uploaded four episodes
which is like yeah it's a serious
serious day it's audio only my video guy
looks after video so it's not
quite the the challenge that you may
come up against but still a serious day
of full graft
um so that and a can of knockout a
caffeinated kind of knockout
and that for me puts me in a really
really nice head space but the number of
people
who are so they're so keen i appreciate
the messages that i get but
everyone's looking for that edge in the
in a pill form or in a a canned form or
in a powdered form
um as opposed to dude you really should
just
learn space repetition or dude you
really should just understand what
pomodoro's or focused like work is
yeah absolutely i think if you're in the
yeah i i i strongly suspect that
okay sort of drugs and neurotropics and
stuff
it's not actually going to be the thing
that that moved the needle the thing
that that moves the needle is testing
yourself more and
spacing it out and interleaving and
maybe if you're operating at sort of
you know the upper echelons of of
everything where every single minute
percentage of optimization is necessary
then maybe you can look into those
but so if you know we're all still
rereading our text and making notes and
thinking
it's going to be helpful like there's a
long way to go before we need to
enhance our performance in that sense we
sing from the same hymn sheet here mate
uh so we've we're there we've we know
what we're going to do
um sitting down are you doing it in
blocks
uh partly so if i'm working with friends
uh will
pomodoro together as a pomodoro method
25 minutes on five minutes off
um when i was at university i used to
get a lot of my friends
who were doing different subjects we'd
all sit in the same table at the library
this is one of those fancy you know
mahogany dark dark
dark mode libraries and we would uh sort
of tap on the table once
when a pomodoro session was going to
begin and then we'd tap on it once when
it ended and then we do a double tap
when our five minute break was over and
we called ourselves the pomodoro society
in which we turned into a whatsapp group
called
pomsoc which is still active to this day
because we actually became pretty good
friends over the course of
exam terms just by studying together for
25 minutes on five minutes off
um and then so in the 25 minutes we'd be
doing our thing
and 25 minutes is actually quite a short
amount of time especially when you're
grappling with a new concept
and i quite like it because it forces
you to
do things a little bit more efficiently
and think okay i've actually only got 25
minutes to try and understand this topic
i'm not going to screw around with stuff
that i know is going to be pointless
levels of detail
i'm going to focus on the big picture
and really try to try to
you know get the broad brushstrokes down
initially and only worry about the
details later
so that was what i personally used to
use these days i'm i'm usually studying
on my own so i don't need to use it as
much but i think pomodoro is really
great for when you're studying with
friends
cool and what are you doing here so
you've got textbook in front of you
are you entering stuff into somewhere
else the way you can re-test yourself is
there a process that people can follow
for this obviously
they just get given they might have some
example exam
questions but a lot of the time you just
given a body of work
and then said some of this is going to
occur in in an exam
in a few months time good luck guys yeah
so i think
it really varies and the way i think
about it is
i treat the exam as if it's a game and
i'm thinking about how i can game the
exam
because very quickly students realize
that
or at least students who do well realize
that
learning the subject is not the same
thing as doing well in the exam
and unfortunately the education system
and the testing system is designed
to encourage us to gain the exam rather
than to encourage us to
understand and appreciate and learn the
content and
so you're sort of operating in a
different mode here the mode isn't
i'm going to learn this body of work and
hope some of it comes up it's
i'm going to see what's come up in every
exam paper that they've published for
the last like
20 years i'm going to try and predict
patterns of questions i'm going to
figure out what's coming up most often
and i'm going to then study for the
purposes of doing well in the exam
rather than i'm going to study to
understand the subject i mean starting
to understand the subject is fine
but if we care about optimizing a
performance on an external test
which may or may not be useful then it's
about
you know thinking about how how can i
gain the exam and then based on whether
the exam is a multiple choice or a short
answer or essays
the study tactics generally vary but
they're all kind of based around
creating questions for yourself and
testing yourself repeatedly over a very
long period of time
so you would actually become your own
examiner exactly yeah
and i would think you know if i were the
examiner
what would i write an essay question on
and i would try and predict
20 essay questions that might come up
that year uh
even though we only would have to write
five of them in the exam and then i can
prepare answers for all 20
of them so that when the exam rolls
around you know i'm not going to get 100
of them right but
chances are at least some of them
because i'm now so familiar with the
subject and i've put myself into the
shoes of the examiner
you know chances are i will have
prepared some of the stuff that they're
going to ask me
that seems a little bit further down the
line from when you're perhaps first
introduced to a topic or perhaps you've
sat down at a lecture or let's say
someone's doing continuous professional
development they've been on a course for
a day or something like that
and then they're like right i'm going to
go away and begin to even become
familiar with this particular
piece of work what happens in between
that and the
and the proper retesting phase are there
like little mini tests that you would do
yeah sort of um so the so step one is
something i call
scoping the subject which is basically
just get an overview of what is in
like what is everything within the
subject uh
so let's say you're studying at a human
physiology
and it's it's very easy kind of in week
one of medical school to open up chapter
one of your massive
huge ass physiology textbook and think
right i'm gonna start from chapter one
the problem with that is that it's just
generally a bad way of reading anything
nonfiction
uh because what you want to do is you
want to get an outline a skeleton
structure in your head of what is
what is everything within this field and
then where is the thing that i
specifically want to work on and where
does it fit into the bigger picture
so within human physiology you might be
like oh actually there's only really
seven topics here
there's nerves there's the heart there's
the lungs the kidneys digestion
endocrine and
thermoregulation seven topics within
physiology every single thing that i
need to know learn
fits into those seven topics that
becomes instantly a lot more manageable
than thinking i've got this 18 000 page
physiology textbook to go through and
we're thinking okay let me start with
chapter one nerves
what are they what are the different
topics within nerves and then you think
okay there's actually only five topics
with the nerves there's this
this and that and conveniently our
lectures were organized into five
great okay so now that i know what the
five topics are let me look at lecture
number one
and now before i start reading lecture
number one let me make a list of all of
the subheadings within lecture number
one
so again at every level of detail
i start off with the big picture and
understanding and
understanding the skeleton structure and
then when it comes to hanging details on
that
i'll i'll be able to do that and so
yeah step one would be scoping the
subject and then step two would be
for me personally as as i'm going
through the content i'll be writing
questions for myself
these days i use notions so i use the
toggle feature so i would write a
question and
hide the answer underneath the toggle or
just screenshot the answer from a pdf or
you know just assume i'll be able to
look up the answer later the answer is
not the important part the important
part is the question and so i'll spend
a little bit of time crafting the
question for my future self
um and once i've crafted it and i've got
this list of toggles
then i can that is sort of my
step-by-step process for going through
anything that i'm trying to learn give
us an example
of a question that you might write
yourself in a subsequent answer
uh sure let me open up my notion
i can actually screen share with you if
you like okay this is gonna be on a
video
uh yeah if that's if that'll work it's
the first time for everything video guy
dean's gonna be losing his mind here
all the filters that he's put on your
face are going to go crazy right there
we go
uh oh i was actually taking notes from
this book how to take smart notes
uh which was actually about all of this
like recall stuff
uh and the power of testing and spacing
when when it came to the con
the context of understanding information
from from notes
but so for example here and i'll kind of
describe it for people who are just
listening to the podcast although you
should subscribe to the youtube channel
am i right
thank you ali i tell you what can i have
you here
if i can just have you here do my intros
and outros every week that would be
wonderful
that sounds dreamy anyway so let's here
let's take
pathology for for example you can see
here that
i i've got like headings for everything
like 1.1
growth adaptations 1.2 cell injury 1.3
cell death 1.43 radical injury
and then within that i've got a load of
toggles so for example within 1.3
cell death the first toggle says what
are the three buzz words for nucleus
dying
and i think the answer is like hypnosis
coilocosis and something else that i
can't remember
hypnosis carrier x's and carylysis
nucleus shrinking down breaking up in
nucleus into pieces and breaking down of
those pieces into bits
uh and so like i haven't just written
the notes
like a a student who hasn't learned
about effective studying techniques
would just write down the notes whereas
what i've done is i've put them within
a toggle equally i've got another one
that says necrosis
six types and so when i when i see that
i'm thinking okay i need to now
spontaneously come up and recall
all of the six different types of
necrosis so let's see if i can get like
liquefactive
gangrenous oh come on now the internet's
listening
for
ah [ __ ] yes i should that liquefactive
fat fibrinoid cases gangrenous and
cognitive
and you can see over here that i've
actually highlighted some of them in red
so those are the ones that i didn't know
about
last time i tested myself on this topic
and at the top
i've said the last time i tested myself
on this was the 7th of july
so that's quite a while ago i haven't
done pathology in a while
and i've just sort of roughly rated how
good i was at doing the thing
and i said that i really sucked at the
topic so as
i'm going through every everything i'm
writing is
uh nested within a toggle that asks me a
question and that makes it very easy for
me
to say okay i'm more [ __ ] at this less
[ __ ] at that more [ __ ] at this
and then as i'm going through stuff if i
don't have a lot of time i can focus on
the reds
but if i have time i'll just do the
whole thing
i'm so so impressed with the
changes i went to uni in 2006 and
finished my masters in like 2011
and i'd never heard of evernote uh i
doubt that notion even existed back then
anki might have been a thing but i was
doing two business degrees that probably
wouldn't have been
super appropriate for me and um now
it feels like this particular studying
method really has a wonderful sort of
technological component to it
um where people are having this
learning style facilitated by some great
apps and tools
so is there anything before we move on
to said apps and tools
is there anything else to sort of
bookend with regards to the
note-taking question making uh
process yeah i think just to emphasize
that
the more i study for for these exams the
more i realized that
still looking at you're still looking at
cell death ally and not your lovely face
and lovely lighting
let's let's cancel the screen share so
you can see my lovely face there we go
um
yeah the more i study for these exams
the more i realized that the writing of
the question is probably the most
important thing
uh i i had a friend who was a couple of
years below me and he ended up ranking
like top
three in in the med school every year
and
he never wrote any notes all he did was
just write hundreds and hundreds of
questions for himself
and i would i would see his word
document he was he was just using
standard
standard word documents because he
couldn't be bothered to use something
fancy like notion
and it would just be a long list of
questions and i'd be like how how would
you deal with this question he would be
like yeah i'll just go through the
questions when i'm studying
and if i don't know the answer i'll look
i'll either google it or
search for it on wikipedia or just
control effort in the lecture notes
i'll be like whoa that's such a low-tech
solution to the same problem it just
works so well
um and so for example i spent absolutely
ages making these notes about six types
of necrosis
but i could have just written a question
for myself uh saying what are the six
types of necrosis and describe each of
them in detail
and then i would have saved a lot of
time when doing the studying and i would
have been focusing on doing the recall
so i think yeah the more we shift our
focus towards writing questions and
answering them
just the the better we'll do we'll do in
our exams although
having said that it's very hard to get
away from the security blanket which is
writing notes and writing answers for
the questions for ourselves
and i still haven't fully gotten away
from that the the tether is difficult to
cut right
yeah exactly it's like it's hard to read
a textbook without a highlighter in your
hand even though you know highlighting
is totally pointless and effective
right yeah if i if i double if i do this
one in pink
that means i'm really really gonna
remember pink's pink's the pink's the
proper [ __ ]
um so before we move on to the tools are
there any uh subjects or
areas um that you think that
this sort of approach that we're going
to go through that we are going through
doesn't work for
yeah i think it works less good for
things like maths and physics which are
more
skills based and based on applying
principles and using your brain
it works very well for things like
medicine which is purely about rote
memorization
but i think even with maths and physics
what they've figured out is that
the more problem sheets you do the more
questions you go through the better
you'll do
so there's a less of a memorization
component to those subjects and much
more of a just
you know do loads of questions figure
out where you went wrong and
hopefully over time your brain will
become good at spotting the patterns
that you need to
understood so into the the bullets in
the magazine of the
rifle that you're firing at this exam
what are the what are the individual
bullets that you're using
anything on your phone anything on your
computer
yeah um probably
i sometimes think about this that if i
could go through med school and i only
had
like like the bare minimum of tools
i think it would be two things i think
firstly it would be anki
anki is a flashcard app and secondly it
would be spider diagrams
i think with anki plus spider diagrams
you can actually memorize or and
understand and learn every single thing
in medical school
uh to just like a stupidly high level
what are you using for spider diagrams
oh pen and paper
all right okay real real real old school
real old school pen and paper or if you
want to
want to be fancy about it notability
ipad pro apple pencil
paper like screen protector um not
sponsored unfortunately
but i know like honestly still for
spider diagrams i just use pen and paper
why is why do you like the spider
diagrams just to visualize how concepts
fit together
exactly yeah because something like anki
flash cards uh are very good at
helping you memorize the detail but
they're very bad at helping you see the
bigger picture
uh and whereas with a spider diagram or
a mind map
you have like the topic in the middle
and then you you're forced to categorize
it into different bits
and the fact that thing certain things
are always at certain parts of the page
that's yet another visual cue for you to
recall that when when you're tested on
it
um and so one thing that i always do is
i try and fit the entire syllabus
for every topic onto a single page so
within hematology for example i'll be
like okay
let's look at all these topics let's try
and sub categorize them as much as
possible
so okay hematology can broadly be split
up into three things uh blood clotting
anemia and cancer and so okay cool now
everything within blood clotting well it
can be this or that
now within cancer we've got these five
different types of hematological
malignancies
and within what's the third one uh
within anemia we've got these three
different types of anemia
and so this sort of spiders out from my
central topic of hematology
and now when it comes to something like
uh you know
understanding henoch online purpura or
some rogue disease like
idiopathic thrombocytopenic purple or
something like that uh
with flash cards i'll know the details
but with my spider diagram i'll know
where it fits into the bigger picture
uh and between those two things i think
you basically cover cover all your bases
that's another david epsteinism right
where he talks about
being birds in the sky and frogs in the
mud says that you
yeah absolutely i like yeah i love that
analogy by barbelling
and having the extremes at both ends the
big picture thinking and then the the
real detailed thinking
um so give me your
60 second elevator pitch for how to how
to nail anki
oh okay cool how to nail anki um anki's
a flashcard app
you wanna firstly download it and set
your appropriate settings by following
any youtube tutorial for the appropriate
anki settings because the default ones
aren't very good
and then you create a deck and a deck of
flashcards you can just kind of use one
deck you can use multiple decks if you
want but let's say you've just got one
deck which is for all of medicine
now anytime you come across something
where you think okay i'm struggling to
understand slash remember this and
i could do with a flashcard you just
write a flashcard for yourself you ask
yourself the question
you put an answer and you try and put as
much information into the answer as
possible so that next time you come
across it
you'll see the answer but you'll also
see the context around it and you can
screenshot from your textbook or
screenshot from wikipedia shove it into
the flashcard
over time as you keep up with your daily
reviews
all of this information that's in your
in your anki will just get uploaded to
your brain
by default provided you just do it every
day and if you can commit to doing that
just doing anki a little bit every day
and getting through your daily reviews
you will i'll 100 guarantee all of the
information in there is going to get
uploaded to your brain
every med student that i know uses
anki and that again like to just sing
the song
of medical students having it having it
a bit hard at university
um you guys if it works for you um
for a business degree like thinking back
to the way that i remembered stuff
doing a degree which really was a walk
in the park
i made it so much harder than it needed
to be like so
so so much harder than it needed to be
but again like exposure to
tools like anki and concepts like space
repetition i hadn't sort of really had
those
um so hopefully we'll have expedited a
bunch of people's discomfort today
what else have we not covered that is
important as a part of the
learning and remembering anything fast
framework
i think we've covered most of the basis
we haven't talked about things like
sleep and exercise and food i suspect
you've covered that a lot on other
episodes of your podcast why don't you
um
give us your protocol let's say that
you're in the
the depths of revision time yeah
how do you ensure that the body the mind
is primed for uh
for uh taking information um
i don't really have an elaborate thing
for this i just make sure i get between
seven and eight hours of sleep every
night and i make sure i don't skip meals
uh and that is actually most of what you
need to do
man how many students or even
people doing a a professional
qualification an mba you know whatever
it might be
the first thing to go is the food
quality it's a diet it's i've spent all
day in the library
back and forth to the vending machine
living on like four packs of monster
munch and and mountain dew
energy like what do you think
the myelin sheaths that your that your
brain is relying on
are made up of mountain dew energy and
pickled onion monster munch
yeah it's probably not entirely good for
the mining um
but yeah you know i don't i don't
overcomplicate it too much recently from
listening to dave asprey and
i think uh natalya did a tweet the other
day about all of the different tech he
uses to hack his sleep
i started kind of looking into this a
little bit more i i do have blackout
curtains in my room which which help
um i i don't bring my phone into bed
with me i always have it across the room
so i'm forced to wake up in the morning
to turn my alarm off
you know just simple things like that i
haven't yet gone down the route of
melatonin pills or light blocking
glasses or
any any of the fancier stuff let me
once we've finished man i'm going to
link you in with the guys from rat
optics
uh matt marooka who's been on this show
the most advanced blue blocking glasses
on the planet
um i'll uh i'll loop you in with them
because they are phenomenal amazing have
they got prescription varieties because
i do wear glasses so they can do dude
they can even do custom ones
um it's insane they're really really fun
uh anyone that was interested in that
the light diet go back and listen to it
it's like episode 189
um so yeah i think certainly talking
about sleep like keeping your phone
outside of your room
uh making sure that you're not uh i'm
just throwing a pair of
optics so these are the these are the
day ones and i've got the night ones
over by bed
one day oh yeah so they're for if you
were working
um during the day but using an
artificial screen and then the red ones
are the
you'll have seen them before they're
like the the hardcore sort of
what the guys in the modern wisdom big
dick group called the turbo nonce
glasses
um okay the horns that just
scream in cell um haven't heard that
phrase since my last lads hang out
i know yeah yeah me neither me neither
but it's just it's one that came up and
it's stuck now for anyone that wears
like
hardcore blue blockers um so yes
sleep important diet important don't
miss meals
uh what else was in there exercise
yeah i kind of fail on the exercise
front a little bit i got a personal
trainer recently
uh but i was meant to have a session
with him yesterday but i just overslept
it was it was really weird like every
single day i set my alarm but as i was
going to bed that night my iphone was
like at one percent and
it was like slowing down and i could
sense it's going to turn off in the next
like 10 seconds
so i thought you know what i'm not going
to set the alarm it's only midnight i
need to wake up at 8 o'clock anyway
i'll just wake up naturally and then i i
fell asleep and the next thing i knew it
was 12 o'clock in the afternoon and i
had my personal trainer session at 10.
and i was just like okay i need to set
an alarm i cannot trust myself to
actually wake up on time
without i think uh i said naval
ravikant's a big proponent he says that
um
you know that your life is in the right
place when you're able to wake up
without an alarm
but that's all well and good when you're
the owner of angel list and
worth like several mil and all that you
do is is
think and make money all day neval uh
for those of us that have got a pt
session at 10 o'clock in the morning we
probably need an alarm um
sleep what about sort of stable sleep
and wake pattern do you also try and
commit to that
it's like revision at the same sort of
time do you find that's easy as a
routine
yeah when i was in the depth of exam
preparation i would have quite a strict
sort of bedtime thing in that i would
always make sure i'm in bed by 11.
usually i'd be reading some extra book
related to my exams
from 11 until i fell asleep and then i'd
always wake up at eight
have breakfast and then go to the
library and get into the library by half
past eight and i'd be essentially being
the library from a half past eight
up until like 10 11 p.m uh only
sort of leaving to take uh food and
toilet breaks
well that was like my hardcore exam
revision what about burnout
you know you start finding yourself
bouncing off the limiter with stuff
how do you know when you're pushing too
hard
i don't know this is something i've
never really struggled with i think
partly because i always study with my
friends
i think if i locked myself up by myself
and said right i need to really optimize
my productivity i'm going to
focus on studying by myself it would
have been a lot harder but because every
day was
fun because i was just hanging out with
my friends and in our five minute
pomodoro breaks we'd be sharing like
memes and stuff
i never really experienced any signs of
burnout so i'm not really very good at
commenting on that
that's an interesting one the the group
um
the group revision i imagine is very
very dependent on getting the right
group
because if you have one bad apple who is
sharing
sharing memes 13 minutes into a pomodoro
exactly
everyone is [ __ ] yeah
i think it's one it's one of those
things where you do kind of need to rule
with an iron fist
it's like is that the ru is that the
rule of pom sock yeah that's a real palm
sock
it's like the palm is sacred the problem
has to happen
i think at least among among everyone i
knew
everyone appreciated it when someone was
taking charge and just
telling them no shut the [ __ ] up we're
gonna sit down and study for the next 25
minutes
and if anyone speaks they're out of the
room like you need that level of
autocracy to
to make it make the system work but
everyone is grateful for it
in the end i get it which is like i
guess i suppose what a dictator would
also say
that it's for the good of the people but
it genuinely is the good of the people
i love it um i think we've got a really
nice sort of overview there
learning remembering stuff um
to finish up we've got we probably
squeeze another 10 minutes in or so
what have you found over the last year
or so
which has changed the most uh to do with
your productivity setup
or that you've been the most impressed
with um that you've added in
or taken out or or switched around with
to do with your
efficiency and productivity oh
interesting question okay so two things
come to mind number one is friction uh i
have this phrase which is that friction
is the most powerful force in the
universe
uh and when it's against us we're not
going to do anything and when it's
in our favor we're not going to do bad
things uh friction in my context
was that for the last like three years
since my youtube channel started
i have been using kind of a light stand
with like a soft box and all this sort
of stuff
which is a real bull lake to set up and
take down and so either my living room
would just be a complete tip at all
times because
the old dc stands lying around with
wires all over the place
or it would be such a bullock to sit
down and film a video because i knew i
would know it would take half an hour to
actually set up all the equipment
but a couple weeks ago i think was last
week i decided i was going to
get a handyman in like cambridge
handyman.uk or something like that
to just ceiling mount one of my lights
and now i have a
kind of aperture space light mounted
above my desk
where previously a c-stand would have
gone from halfway down the living room
across through the desk
and just that one difference has made
such a huge impact to my video making
process because
it's literally a case of i've got the
remote control over here i press the
power button i turn the light on
and i've got the camera already ready to
go so then it's just a case of putting
the microphone in place and then and
then i'm good to go
earlier today i was thinking of doing an
unboxing and again i had to set up a
c-stand to get an overhead camera rig
and i was thinking okay
this is not sustainable in the long term
i need to get like a warm
like a ceiling mounted retractable
overhead rig or i can just do this and
it's fine
um and so every time like like now i'm
very
because i think i think even before i
was quite attuned to friction
but i just hadn't considered that it
would actually be roi positive to spend
200 quid to hire a handyman to come and
sort my ceiling mount out and this stuff
but it that almost certainly is the case
so really i'm
what i'm trying to do now is figure out
anytime i feel a sense of uh i don't
want to do this
i sort of try and examine where is that
feeling coming from and can i eliminate
friction to get rid of that feeling
and often the answer is yes i just have
to get this thing to make something a
little bit more convenient
so that's one thing the other thing is i
recently got this herman miller sale
chair
i've been lusting after herman miller's
militarist for the last 10 years and my
mom always vetoed it she was like no
you're not spending a thousand pounds on
a chair
uh but if a few months ago i ordered
this one without telling her so it's
fine
and then when the guy came to deliver it
it was like one of the hermann miller
like
ergonomic specialists and stuff and so i
ended up having a chat with him and he
was giving me some tips on how to set it
up
and the main takeaway was that
apparently what he recommends is that
you have
the arm rests of the chair and just
above your desk
and norm so like before my desk was
fairly high
now i've sort of lowered it a lot
because it's a standing desk
and now when i sit down i have like a
really
good ergonomic position which is just
something i i hadn't even considered
before
and now over the last over the last week
or so since i've had this i actually
haven't had any lower back pain which i
would always get when
using my desk in standing mode or when
using any other any other kind of setup
so this is another area where i'm i'm
thinking oh this ergonomic thing is
pretty legit
i got this like rest palm rest for my
keyboard the other day
um which makes it more comfortable to
type and means my my
my wrists are in a less flexed position
normally
so that's the sort of stuff i'm thinking
about in in terms of
in terms of modern productivity it's
interesting i think
we were talking earlier on unless you're
at the absolute
peak tip of the spear zenith of your
productivity you probably don't need
nootropics
i think based on the content that comes
off your youtube channel
the thousand pound chair and the the
wrist
optimizing like a rest thing when you
type in 140 words per minute that's you
you kind of need that
right that makes it doesn't make a
difference it just feels a lot nicer and
it feels less painful at the end of the
day so i'm thinking you know what
any amount of money i can spend to make
my life more pleasant in this regard
is absolutely going to be roi positive
talking about the friction thing i think
that's a really interesting point i've
always been a fan of the stacking the
deck concept
which is that you want to make the
things that you do want to do as easy as
possible and the things that you don't
want to do as hard as possible
stack the deck in your favor so for
instance you're someone who
has their phone over the far side of the
room i've had mine outside of my bedroom
in the kitchen for
like two and a half years and my sleep
quality i
wasn't tracking it as closely as i am
now with a a wearable
um but my sleep quality must have
increased within two weeks by 10
because you always know like you
remember when you used to have your
phone next to your bed
and you there was just in the back of
your mind there was always that
you can't sleep there's cat videos on
youtube
and then you roll over and he's there
and the cat videos are there and then
three hours later it's three a.m
and you hate yourself you hate you you
hate yourself the core of your being
yeah these days the only thing i have on
my bedside table i
i i caved i think two years ago and got
one of those dyson
desk fans that look nice and are cool so
i always have the fan on and i have a
kindle on my bedside table
so if i get to the point where anytime i
get to the point where i can't sleep
i'll just stop reading on the kindle
uh and recently i actually got the
kindle oasis i'd been a kindle paper
white
guy for the last like five years but the
kindle oasis is like five times more
expensive
but it does have a warm light and i was
thinking you know what
i can make a video review about this
plus the warm light will be better for
me in my sleep so now i have the kindle
oasis purely for that reason
um and it's quite nice because now i
will just read
and then i'll find my eyes closing and
then i'll just fall asleep which is
quite a nice place to be and with the
oasis you can read in the bath
and just drop it in drop it yeah feel
free to drop it in i just read with the
paperwhite in the box as well i just
never never drop it in but now i know i
can drop it in
yeah interesting thing i've got a study
that i can send to you
uh that compares the effect of e-readers
versus tablets on melatonin production
oh okay um e-readers are fine this one
out
in this one out in my newsletter if
anyone was uh
read the three-minute monday newsletter
this week um it was talking about the
i'd said by kindle it's the easiest way
to make reading
if you want to get into reading a little
bit more um it's the easiest way to make
it frictionless again
um and don't be concerned about
reading on the night time the study that
i've seen
one study yeah fair enough but like the
evidence suggests
that it doesn't impact your sick
melatonin production so read away man
[ __ ] the warm light
go white light maybe i should switch to
paper right now people
study to include in my review video of
oasis versus paperwhite
um but yeah on the on the kindle note
the kindle is one of the three things
that i say is a genuinely life-changing
piece of tech
kindle being number one airpods being
number two just because it reduces the
friction to listening you are amongst
your friends here ali you are
a subscription to audible being number
three because a subscription to audible
is absolutely it's
the if i could only subscribe to one
thing it would be a subscription to
audible
dude it's like um you know when people
arrive
in the world like you're born and you
should be issued with a starter pack
and it's like here you are little
jonathan uh
little sophie here's his here's your
kindle
here's your horrible subscription and a
pair of airpod pros
there you go oh yeah those are my three
life-changing
life-changing pieces of tech i love it
man what would mine be i think mine
would
almost definitely be airpods cost
per hour used they are
by far significantly more than even my
phone
you know um the the best thing that i've
bought
um probably a sunrise alarm clock oh
interesting
makes makes a fairly bit to the guy at
the bottom down there
um yeah i actually had one of those i
ended up throwing it away because i'm
giving it away i can't
because i just didn't didn't really use
it really so just for me i i want to
uh i've got some fairly bad habits
around my phone um as
many of the people that are listening
might do and um
a way that i've found the best way that
i've found is to stack the deck
by it not being near me like if my phone
is out of
arm's reach then i can't use it um use
whatsapp web for
messaging on desktop and
instagram can also be used through
desktop or you can download flume
which is a desktop app for mac for
instagram if you want to use that for
uploading
twitter again facebook again imessage
etc etc just do everything through your
computer
and then if you've got airpod pros that
have got always on siri you can just hey
siri any of the [ __ ] that you needed to
do through your phone in any case
so it makes your phone essentially
redundant um
so yeah i think it would be it would be
probably sunrise alarm clock
airpods
oh automatic car driving automatic
car really dude manual cars don't tell
me driving on your car
no you've got tesla i've been driving a
manual car for the last like
eight years bro has your life not been
completely changed by not having to use
the left-hand side of your body
no it really hasn't i've
has my life actually changed by not
needing to change gear but changing gear
was such a
second nature thing i didn't even notice
i was doing it maybe
maybe in cambridge there's just not
enough nose-to-tail traffic
do you know how flamingos flamingos
sleep like one half of their body
at a time so they can put you can be a
flamingo
with an automatic car you are a flamingo
okay um
i'll have to test that a little bit more
i'll i'll actively think about it a bit
more now that you've mentioned it to be
like okay
is driving this actually making a
difference the autopilot is great for
traffic so i'll just turn that on so i
don't have to think
when i'm done do you get the the full
upgrade of oh no i didn't i didn't get
any upgrades but they still have
autopilot when you're in traffic so it's
pretty way
yeah that's cool man i'm excited to see
what life in a
tesla in the uk is like i spent a lot of
time in america a couple of years ago
in a model 3 when it just came out um
but that was
la traffic which is nose-to-tail on
motorways and then
they've got supercharged stations every
20 kilometers um and it was a lot of
kind of big open driving
um but the integrations and stuff like
that are
sick so uh yeah man look we uh
i feel like we could keep on going on
forever and i'm sure that we'll have a
reason to get you back on
in future but for the people who are
interested in what we've gone through
today where should they go to check out
more of your stuff
uh sure uh so probably my youtube
channel is the main place so if you just
search ali abdul
on youtube abd double a-l and you'll
find it
alternatively you can go to my website
aliabdel.com and that'll have links to
podcast
newsletter instagram the horsha bank
dude thank you so much for today
good stuff thanks for having me on
you